[Music]
the whisper war may be over but the
premiere of the walking dead six bonus
season 10 episodes is proof that in the
apocalypse there are always new threats
waiting to emerge
released on amc plus on sunday february
21 2021
a full week before its cable debut on
february 28th the new episode entitled
home sweet home picks up in the
aftermath of the bloody season 10b
finale and wastes no time answering some
lingering questions
long time walking dead fans will likely
be thrilled to see that not only is this
new installment maggie centric
but it also features lauren cohan once
again listed as a main cast member on
the series
home sweet home packs a lot of action
and exposition into its 41 minute run
time
viewers get the lowdown on what maggie
has been up to since she disappeared
from the show back in season 9 as well
as deeper insight into the intimidating
masked survivor we saw her with when she
reappeared in the season 10b finale
and returning to the show maggie also
brought with her a potential new threat
to the survivors in alexandria that's
not even to mention the complications
her arrival could pose for negan's place
in the community
here's what went down in the walking
dead season 10's first bonus episode
home sweet home
and what the events and reveals could
signify for the future
after being absent since a time jump in
the middle of season 9
maggie returned with new allies in tow
to help silence the threat of the
whispers
since leaving alexandria maggie has been
traveling from community to community
with her son herschel
we only meet two members of the group
she's currently with at the beginning of
the episode as the rest are hunker down
at a base camp with young herschel
maggie and her new allies team up with
daryl and kelly to find their way back
to the rest of the group
through this mission it becomes clear
that maggie's strength compassion and
determination have made her a natural
leader for this new group
she has a particularly close
relationship with elijah the formerly
unnamed mass survivor we met in the
season 10b finale
elijah's silent and intimidating
appearance made some fellow survivors
uneasy however in this episode we get
some surprising insight into his
character while the group is camping out
overnight on their way to meet up with
maggie's people
kelly wanders off while she's supposed
to be on guard duty she's discovered the
next morning inspecting some clothing on
a crashed truck nearby
and maggie confronts her about her
abandonment of the group daryl explains
that in the midst of everything else
kelly is still trying to find her sister
connie who has been missing since
earlier in season 10. maggie accepts
this explanation and tells kelly that
elijah also recently lost his own sister
when the group gets entangled in a
dangerous situation later on in the
episode kelly notices that elijah seems
to be frozen in fear
she asks him to lift up his mask he does
and reveals that he's a young man who
does indeed look incredibly anxious
about the danger they found themselves
in
for elijah the scary mask he wears is
quite literally a cover to shield
himself from the outside world
with it on people are intimidated by it
but only because they can't see that
underneath he's the one who's terrified
kelly gives him a quick pep talk and
later elijah shares some food with her
to cement their budding friendship
it remains to be seen whether elijah
will become stronger and more confident
moving forward which would be beneficial
to him and his fellow survivors the
inevitable
next time they're in trouble or if the
dangers of the world around him will
become too much and cause him to slip
further into fear and potentially lead
to a tragic end
the walking dead has seen enough depth
and destruction over the years so
hopefully elijah's narrative arc will be
a positive uplifting one
or at least as positive and uplifting as
things can get in a zombie show
maggie's journey to reunite with the
rest of her group takes a tragic turn
when she arrives at the shelter they've
been using and finds it ransacked and
burned to the ground
there are several dead bodies among the
wreckage but herschel is missing
although the perpetrators of this attack
are nowhere to be seen maggie and her
allies seem to know exactly who did it
the reapers whom cole believes have been
following their group
the crew splits up to find any survivors
of the attack and eventually maggie and
daryl come across three other members of
her group who got away however someone
with a sniper rifle hiding in the woods
quickly picks the trio
off the sniper eventually emerges and
reveals himself to be completely decked
out and camouflaged in tactical gear
after a scuffle maggie and daryl get the
upper hand against the sniper
maggie attempts to get answers out of
the man whose group has been attacking
them for seemingly no reason
who are you who are you what do you call
yourselves
instead of giving her answers the man
pulls the pin out of a grenade strapped
to his chest and blows himself up
it's unclear what exactly the reaper's
true purpose is especially since they
don't have any connections to the
walking dead comics
considering that the sniper was equipped
with several weapons was wearing a tire
designed for stealthiness and was
outfitted in tactical gear it seems
plausible that the reapers members may
have military experience from their
lives pre-zombie apocalypse they may
even be offshoots of or somehow related
to the commonwealth or possibly the
civil republic military
whatever their background is clear that
the reapers aren't some slap together
faction of survivors who are winging
things
they're organized ruthless and will
evidently stop at nothing to meet their
goals
whatever those goals may be regardless
of what their mission ends up being this
certainly isn't the last we'll see of
this new enemy in the walking dead
season 10.
after the run in with the reaper's
sniper maggie goes off to find her son
thankfully for maggie she's raised young
herschel in her resourceful image
and she eventually finds him safe and
hiding in a tree with her son by her
side but her group of shambles maggie
decides
to accompany daryl and kelly back to
alexandria there's the promise of safety
in numbers which maggie needs right now
but returning to alexandria isn't an
easy decision for her
at the beginning of home sweet home
maggie also comes face to face with
negan
viewers have seen his character go
through many twists and turns over the
course of the series but for maggie
he'll always be the man who brutally
killed her husband glenn all those years
ago
it's clear that maggie isn't interested
in living anywhere near negan
and you can't really blame her for that
truth is i left home because i couldn't
have negan taken up any more space in my
head and i
realized i didn't want to bring herself
back to that however throughout the
episode maggie realizes that she has no
choice but to go back to alexandria
where negan lives
she tells carol that she doesn't hold
any hard feelings against her for
bringing negan into the alexandria mix
to help with the whisper situation
and assures daryl that she'll deal with
her feelings for the good of her group
as she walks back into town for the
first time in years maggie wears a look
of pardon determination
the camera lingers on negan as he
watches her walk by possibly indicating
the tensions between him and maggie are
far from over
both characters have undergone huge
changes over the years and things really
could go either way for maggie and negan
as the remaining episodes of season 10
play out
in a perfect world negan never would
have done what he did and maggie could
return to alexandria without any qualms
but it seems the best anyone can do here
is hope that negan and maggie's volatile
pass doesn't make their current
situation any worse than it needs to be
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you